5 years ago you voted maybe not 5 years
ago 10 years ago when you voted you're
voting Democrat versus Republican and
Republicans had the reputation of pro
war party and all this other stuff and
for longest time that's what the case
was totally and then gradually 2016 2015
things changed and then all of a sudden
you started noticing this isn't about
Democrat against Republican it never got
this public remember social media is one
of the best things that ever happened
because it exposes everybody I mean a
guy like you you take social media out
you're not going to be on the debate
stage they would
not soci the equalizer for guy like to
come out and call these guys out to is
the ultimate establishment versus the
anti-establishment vote so on December
6th we're doing the town hall with RFK
what are your thoughts with RFK RFK uh
if you want to pull this up robs you
know on on yesterday tired of Biden and
Trump 10% of swing state voters are back
in RFK he was watching a debate and he
actually liked some of the things that
you said I don't know if you saw when he
was commenting that no yeah so what are
your thoughts about him and who does he
hurt what does this say about today's
election is he a modern day Ros Pro or
is this is a complete different case
study of an independent uh candidate so
I I like I like his spirit I like a lot
of his the spirit I like is the
willingness to challenge The
Establishment in what was his own party
I think his commitment to speaking about
topics that the Democratic party doesn't
want him speaking about and I think of
all of the other candidates I mean I
don't think he has offered the clarity
of exact foreign policy that that I have
if I may say so but or and I don't know
that he's in the details on this stuff
but his instincts are at least
understanding that World War II is a
really bad option to the United States
so I appreciate those things about him
we have some policy disagreements and
those are less important than what I'm
about to say I mean he has in the past I
think said things like and maybe he
doesn't mean mean it anymore but he said
things like people who spread climate
disinformation should be put in jail
look I think the whole climate change
agenda as a hoax we can have that
discussion and let alone even if you
didn't agree with that the answer to
speech you disagree with is not
censorship and and on a good day RFK
knows that too you know he he believes
in affirmative action and racial
reparations I'm against a lot of that I
think it's divisive it's toxics we have
we have our plenty of share policy
agreements but at least I think his
heart is in the right place and he's
somebody who is unafraid to challenge
orthodoxies and I respect that about him
I just wish he wasn't so scared of me
why do you think he's scared oh I mean
the number of networks I mean you should
I I if the dates work out you could
actually offer him the same thing I mean
I can't tell you the number of podcasts
networks Etc that have said hey would
you have an open discussion with RFK I
said absolutely I would do it and every
time he backs out of it and I think that
look I think that if somebody sees the
way that I'm going after other
Republican candidates on the debate
stage I actually would not that would
not be my treatment of RFK I think we
would have in a different format more of
a conversation like you and I are having
and so I think that he I don't I mean I
I could understand why if somebody's
building their brand they don't want the
anti-establishment sheen to wear off if
you're getting you
know called out but I would my goal
wouldn't be to call him out on this
stuff we have some disagreements but
let's have actually and I think he's
probably the one person in American
politics actually put in some Donald
Trump in this category too but that's
about it
who you can actually end up having a
conversation that's unscripted and you
could actually be much more mutually
respectful about your
disagreements and so you know i' I'd
pledge to say that if if he you know
manned up and and agreed to one of those
things I would my goal would not be to
play gotcha with him I mean here's
here's just a fact of the matter is that
different people are different leaders
of different styles right I can't speak
for him but he's not in the details
right in terms of domestic policy or
foreign policy or the
how I'm a CEO by Nature I I you know
enjoy writing reading these books and
things like this and so I am a details
guy but my goal will not be to the
extent that part of his concern would be
because I'm in the details play gotcha
games with him that's not that wouldn't
be the point the point would be to
actually have a conversation that
advances true discourse in the country
in a way that challenges a bipartisan
establishment
that's by and large equally corrupt and
I think he gets that and I respect him
for that but I think that you know if
he's running to be president and this
man wants to and I I don't think he
thinks or anyone thinks he's gonna I
don't think he believes he's in this to
win I think he's believes in this to
move the conversation but if he's
running for president you want to sit
across the table from xiin ping and
you're an advocate for free
speech you know I I I haven't I'm
haven't been the one you know I mean
it's been networks that have repeatedly
been pounding both of us every time I
say yes and every time it's oh he didn't
want to do it and I think that that's a
little bit Unbecoming of him because
this is a guy I love the fact that he's
Fearless go all the way with being
fearless and know that's what I would
say and so maybe he will and so I want
to give him give him room for that but
that's all I would say is the he'll see
this who do you think he he's a good
dude he's a good dude and he's and you
we have our disagreements but if my only
advice to him would be if you're going
to be a free speech guy go free speech
all the way don't do this climate change
missing information censorship garbage
you want to practice Free Speech give
credit what creditors do VC makes some
good points on Ukraine glad to see some
of his some of the awareness of the
Republican Party who do you think he
helps or hurts more that's a little bit
of an that's a a little bit of a light
touch understatement there because I
think I think the good points on Ukraine
is we got to go deep into the details
and it's not just on Ukraine but broader
foreign policy but he's he's a
thoughtful guy and so I think a lot of
good would come out of an open
conversation but I just think if you're
running for US president
this applies to me applies to everybody
hold me to the standard call me out if
I'm not doing this at some point too
right and I get it because my sense is
if you look at people who are running
his campaign you got a lot of swamp
creatures from prior Democratic
establishment campaigns and I have you
know I I I I get this if you're
surrounded by an establishment that can
still shave off a little bit of the edge
I'd say bring back the inner you and
let's actually lay it out on the table
and so yeah if you talk to him I would
just my encouraging the thing I would do
and I've talked to him a couple times in
this campaign I think that you know he's
he's doing a lot of important things you
guys have spoken yeah we spoken a few
times yeah yeah and I told him the same
thing when I talked to him too is
practice what you preach when it comes
to free speech and free speech is about
a culture and an example that you set
for the country you know Barry Goldwater
I think um was it him and and JFK
whoever it was me they talked about
potentially flying around the country on
the same plane you know do do Lincoln
Douglas style debates that doesn't
happen in this country country anymore
and I think there's an opportunity to
set a good example but you got to man up
and there's some risk involved in every
conversation you
have but you got to take that on in a
way that advances the interest of the
country and if you want to sit across
the table from shanping or whoever else
you got to show the people you're fit
enough to sit across the table from
somebody who has different opinions than
you and may have different knowledge
base than you and that's a good thing if
both people are approaching it good I
think if there's a leader bulletin in
who has uh agreed to Face Off anybody
the most anybody opposing supporting
anybody you're number one okay in that I
think number two would be
RFK and then it's just everybody else
it's going to become I give the Santa's
credit for being here Haley didn't want
to be here we invited Nikki Haley she
didn't want to come and talk on a
podcast and doing long form I don't know
if she's done any long form uh podcast
herself it's all going to be prev vetted
pre-scripted you know I'm sure there be
a lot of rules you have to send the
questions in advance and by the way to
give credit to the santis nothing was
off table they they just said hey ask
the question I do give credit especially
for a guy like him where he's not
naturally comfortable doing that or at
least wasn't you know you got to give
credit where credits too I agree with
that so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right
here